la chose la plus importante dans la vie les
bat toujours les gens là en ce
moment ne le veulent pas tu ne me connais pas
tu es sur le point de la mille
saga Furious grandit en mûrissant et en
offrant des aspects que tu n'aurais peut-être
jamais imaginés  dans une action
aussi explosive alors nous l'avons fait
vous vous souvenez d'Owen Shaw celui que nous avons déchiré la
moitié de Londres en Chine a bien
fait c'est un grand méchant frère vous faites ce que
vous devez faire ne manquez pas les guerres à
venir nous sommes  allons les affronter dans les
rues, nous savons mieux ce qui sépare la
franchise en général, c'est notre capacité à
continuer à monter la barre et chaque film
devient de plus en plus intense, nous avons fait passer les
cascades et les séquences d'action
au niveau supérieur,
ce qui a vraiment été amené au suivant
le niveau est l'intégrité émotionnelle de l'
âme
je vais avec vous les thèmes de la famille
cette fraternité voir un homme bon et nous
savons tous que quand il s'agit de la
famille, cela pourrait devenir fou d'accord
presque en surface vous parlez d'
individus disposés  à t  Prenez des balles l'un pour
l'autre
vous roulez en Irak il y a une ligne qui est
venue définir ce que vos 7% représentent à bien des
égards toute la saga Je n'ai pas de
fonds
autre famille faisons celui-ci celui-ci est
spécial parce que c'est un héritage cette fois-
ci ce n'est pas si  beaucoup à propos de la vitesse
des voitures je vous ferais sortir d'ici
celui-ci compte vraiment vous devez dire
au revoir à quelqu'un de très très spécial je
pense que tous les fans vont se sentir bien
qu'il y a un respect là-bas
[Musique]
cette famille de recensement qui existe  dans Love
Actually saigne de l'écran et le
monde entier se sent à part